[Musique]
les nominations
et si on allait se promener
à
il faut bien le dire c'est génial
vétérinaire non tu veut piéger première
fois oui oh le docteur francis est le
meilleur vétérinaire de tous les
vétérinaires
tu vas adorer sa spécialité c'est les
troubles du comportement mais j'ai pas
du tout de troubles du comportement je
jouais vraiment aussi je fais bien c'est
mon humaine qui est des règles
enfin et emachines je lui apporte à nos
oiseaux morts et le jette et je vous
apporte une souris morte à direct à la
poubelle s'est jamais rien mais c'est
bien pour toi même si mon humaine dit
tout le temps tu es un bout tout trouvé
je crois que je suis un bon toutou mais
ici au fond j'étais un méchant tout cas
si j'étais musicien trop bizarre alors
la cause et int encore rien dit